على الساحل الجنوبي لجزيرة نيوزيلندا
على مساحة 150 فدانًا من مكان البطريق البري الخاص ،
هو مركز إنقاذ
وإعادة تأهيل لطيور البطريق الجياع
والمصابين ، كما أنه ملاذ
لهذه الأنواع المحلية المهددة بالانقراض
koiho هي كلمة الماوري للبطريق ذو العين
الصفراء وتعني مأوى صاخبًا  إنها
فرصة بعد أن ترى واحدًا
ستسمعهم يصرخون على بعضهم البعض ،
فهم النوع الوحيد في العالم
من طيور البطريق لذلك لا يحبون
بعضهم البعض
، ولا يبدو أنهم يحبون الاتصال البشري ، كما
يقول الحفاظ على مكان البطريق
صدق أو لا تصدق المدير جيسون فان زانتن ، البطاريق صفراء العينين
ليست لطيفة ومحبوبة كما لو
كانت تبدو وكأنها لديها لدغة شريرة
حقًا ويمكن أن
يتسبب ذلك في ضرر كبير
للعديد من هذه الطيور تأتي إلى
مكان البطريق من مستشفى دنيدن للحياة البرية
في مكان قريب حيث هم تحت رعاية
المؤسس والمخرج الدكتورة ليزا أرجيلا ،
أحب طيور البطريق ، فهم أفراد صغار مثيرون جدًا ،
ولديهم جميعًا
شخصياتهم الفردية أيضًا
هذا هو بطريق
فيوردلاند أو تاواكي ، وهو واحد من أندر
أنواع
طيور البطريق في نيوزيلندا ، الكثير من طيور البطريق النيوزيلندية لدينا في
مثل هذا الصراع
تصل إلى مستويات من التعرض
للخطر فقط في محاولة
لإنقاذ هؤلاء الرجال بأفضل ما يمكننا
لمنعهم من الانقراض
نعم ، تشعر بتحسن
، تعالج الدكتورة أغيلا وفريقها ما يصل إلى 50 من
طيور البطريق هنا في كل موسم ،
ومعظم الإصابات التي نراها هي في الواقع
مرتبطة بالحيوان المفترس ،
وقد حصل هذا الرجل على ما يمكن أن يكون
متسقًا مع جروح البركودا السيئة في
جميع أنحاء القدمين من البركودا على ما
أعتقد  من المؤكد أن تغير المناخ
له تأثير على درجات حرارة
المحيط وماهية الأسماك الموجودة وأين
تتشتت ، لذا قد يكون هذا هو السبب في أننا
نشهد المزيد من
الإصابات
في مكان البطريق هذه الطيور الصغيرة
تشعر بآثار تغير المناخ
غير قادرة على  العثور على ما يكفي من الغذاء في المحيط
بسبب ارتفاع درجات حرارة البحر
وكذلك ممارسات الصيد يقول فان زنتن إن
حوالي 80 في المائة يعانون من نقص
الوزن ويحتاجون إلى
تسمين  لقد كانت هذه الطيور تتراجع كثيرًا
مؤخرًا في السنوات العشر الماضية أو نحو ذلك ،
فقد فقدنا حوالي ثلاثة أرباع أو 75 في
المائة من السكان ، لذا فإن البشر
سريعًا جدًا
أيضًا لديهم دور كبير في لعب
الكثير من شواطئنا العامة للأسف
لدينا الكثير من حركة السير عليها
ونحن نتسبب في الكثير من الإزعاج لهذه
الطيور
الاحتياطيات الخاصة مثل هذه مهمة حقًا
للأنواع
المستمرة ، والعمل الذي نقوم به أمر
بالغ الأهمية لهؤلاء الرجال وبقائهم على
قيد الحياة هنا في البر الرئيسي
لذلك  95 من الطيور التي تأتي إلينا يتم
إطلاقها بنجاح مرة أخرى في
البرية
بحثًا عن طيور
فانزينتون.  فيما يتعلق بالأشخاص الذين
سيتأثرون بتغير المناخ أولاً ،
وأكثر
ما يصرخون علينا ليقولوا إن
المناخ كارثة
، والآن علينا فقط أن نأمل
أن  يمكن للجنس البشري أن يستمع إليهم
لأننا لا نريد أن نفقد هؤلاء الأشخاص